so I'm wondering we've touched multiple
times on the fact that you've been an
entrepreneur and that's really actually
what still defines you and I'm wondering
working with nonprofits which you know
maybe don't have especially web
enterpreneurship you know where you sort
of go from ideation to rapid prototyping
to the alpha version Peter version and
you just try to get through that
pipeline really quickly and and and and
I think that's a very different focus
from some nonprofits which and
especially environmentalism where the
timeline is just a completely different
you know how do you are you how do you
deal with your impatience right on
because because I can you know I can see
myself I'm I'm very involved with with
multiple projects and I love pushing
things forward and I get very impaired
and I've been worked for nonprofit
myself and I clearly know that it's
probably not for me it while I'm yet
while I'm you know before I'm 30 because
I'd be too impatient about it I really
want to see this thing happen now well
something i said earlier which is when
you're making a grant to a non-profit
you are making an investment in that
nonprofit you're just recognizing that
you're not getting a financial return so
if you're going to make an investment in
a non-profit there's a whole decision
process that you're going to say why
should it be this non profit versus net
nonprofit within a non-profit which
activity should I be supporting I think
for Betsy and I the nonprofit's the
large nonprofits that we work with know
what we're all about and they come up to
see us as their venture investors in
some ways and we're very proud of the
funding that we have done with the
largest nonprofits but with small
innovative projects and and so we'll sit
down with the CEO of Fred Krupp as an
example of Environmental Defense or
Francis by Nicki of NRDC and many others
and they'll say hey this is a project
that where we want to work on or we'll
sit Betsy and I on whilst at them and
say hey this is something that we think
you should be working on and we'll talk
about it and if there
is an opportunity for us to provide seed
investment to that project will do that
and we we probably do five of those a
year and again if we're successful then
our seed dollars will lead to other
organizations other foundations getting
behind that and we've done that a stream
of that and I think we've got a good
reputation so that when we do this other
foundations will say all right well if
you know Betsy and Jesse are in it well
then we'll take a look at it as well the
impatience the proud the problems that
they're trying to solve are really
really long problems and I am impatient
and I think over the years I realized
you're just not going to get the result
I thought climate change I actually
thought that there was going to be a
bill passed and I you know like so many
other folks in our sector we really did
and we were almost there and then it
didn't happen and and actually on that
note we all kind of walked away after
Copenhagen fell apart and said now what
do we do you know for eight years this
was our defining moment it was going to
have it and everyone walked myself what
do we do now and and I think all of us
as philanthropists retrenched and said
what do we do what we did was we kind of
went local we said you know what for a
moment let's just stay off of this
global change or our platform because I
don't think we really made a difference
but we can locally and so you can really
see when you're doing something locally
when you're touching a one student or a
community in your backyard or you or
even internationally and you can see
that it made a difference it can happen
but what I would say is as an
entrepreneur and as as investors in
philanthropy we're backing people so
within an organization we tend to
gravitate to the one who's the
entrepreneurial in there you know and
and they know it the large organizations
you know will put out this person in
front of us because they know that we
can we can relate to them and will
typically find a project that we can
support and the result of that project
will have so global climate change is a
big problem and who knows how it's ever
going to get resolved but actually
figuring out how to
renewable energy in new haven or in
Bridgeport or doing urban gardens in New
Haven and Bridgeport or elsewhere in the
world you can touch it you can feel it
and you can see the result and you could
get behind in a social entrepreneur and
do whatever you can to make them
successful can I follow up do you want
to know no I could just because you
mentioned how you you know having almost
been there with the bill and then that
disappointment yeah I was fortunate
enough to just three days ago I learned
that I'm able to get to the
sustainability conference in Rio okay
the + 20 and I I think there's you know
I think a lot of people are looking to
it especially in light of all soaked up
15 yeah you know what are your hopes for
this conference I think the sort of the
cynical view which says well the time of
big conference is sort of over yeah and
then there's sort of a hopeful view
which says well you know we got a shot
at it again and after all it's rio and
it's it's been now 20 years so who knows
what is your take on it well this is
where I could actually give you a really
political answer that probably I
shouldn't thanks Heather you know there
has to be there has to be a political
will what I found in in Copenhagen in
the whole process is that the rest of
the world still looks the United States
to be a leader hi great really great and
so in Copenhagen you know we were trying
to do that at that point in time and
then we backed off and and so a lot of
what was the progress I was made up to
that point is going backwards because
it's it all needs to come together and
it wasn't so the United States has to
figure out again how to lead and and
what does that mean and what shape does
that take different than a large
conference so I'm not sure what will
come out of that conference but i do
think to tie it back to some of the
questions on the investment side if you
can get different constituents paying
attention to environmental issues in
addition to the traditional
environmental list in the world of
philanthropy i believe three percent of
dollars go to environmental issues right
with two orphan it's that
very very small number think we
discussed this early on in class right
so and we you know what we probably know
where all those dollars are coming over
a small group of funders but if you look
at poverty in World Health and other
issues they're much bigger these issues
are the same issues you know the issues
of poverty and water and when you look
at climate change and the things that
are happening and will be happening with
droughts and floods and then we're
seeing it with natural disasters it
really needs to be the intersection and
the environmental community and they did
in Copenhagen can need to continue to
have a much wider tent to realize that
you know it's not about the environment
we live on this earth and we all live us
on this earth and we need to figure out
how to how to coexist in the positive
way so I'm not sure exactly what's going
to come out of that but I where I'm
optimistic I'm optimistic with your
generation I'm optimistic that that
there's so many younger folks who are
figuring out how they want to do things
in their own way and whether they're
starting a for-profit company that they
want to make money we talked to someone
today that has a software platform for
organic farms and for csa so that's a
for-profit business or social
entrepreneurs folks like 350.org that
are running around trying to organize
people and i'm sure there's great groups
here at Yale so I'm optimistic that that
your generation understands the
complexities of what's going on and and
will take a leadership role in our
generation will do everything we can to
support your efforts and our
philanthropy a lot of it is going to
start up early stage nonprofits that
have a different twist on how they want
to do things are collaborating with a
larger nonprofit so they get to
understand those pieces of it that's
that's where I think the future is there
certainly things need to happen at a
global level but I think it's going to
be a lot of bubbling up and eventually
the leadership our leadership in
Washington will look behind and realize
that your folks like you are push
them forward into the right decisions